bonjour bonjour maurizia j'aurai à tous
vos auditeurs vous régulièrement sur les
réseaux sociaux à travers de multiples
réunions d'ailleurs ce soir vous serez à
basse pointe jean philippe miller de ce
côté janvier petit leurs députés du mini
récemment cet esprit il ya comme une
volonté de dire ce qu'on fait à la
population quand on est élu quand on est
parlementaire c'est une nouvelle donne
chez nous une constante vous savez
j'étais conseiller général parti
populaire j'ai été liés à la sécurité à
fort de france et on a toujours
multiplié les contacts avec la
population il faut faire encore plus moi
j'ai tenu et je l'annoncé lors de ma
campagne électorale pour les
sénatoriales à tous les électeurs que je
visitais en particulier les mairies que
je ne vois pas ce mandat de
parlementaire comme étant un mandat
coupé de la réalité et donc j'ai tenu ma
promesse on y temps connecté en
permanence à mon pays savoir ce qui s'y
passe et que c'est très grave parce que
bon on peut être à 8000 km certes on est
avant tout un élu dans tiny classe que
le sujet qui fâche multiplient que les
administrés sont de plus en plus excédés
par ce que la réponse politique parce
que l'action visible tout de suite sur
le terrain ne peut pas être perçue de
façon instantanée
oui puis il faut expliquer aux gens ce
qu'on fait mandat de parlementaire dit
souvent appréhendée de manière
extrêmement confuse on ne sait pas trop
ce qu'on fait là bas beaucoup d'à priori
beaucoup de préjugés
mais lorsque vous allez dans ses
instances et que vous êtes au contact de
la population et vous leur expliquer ce
que vous faites toute transparence je
publie mon agenda chaque semaine j'ai
comme convenu j'ai ouvert
nous avons tous les deux sénateurs
ouvert notre permanence depuis
maintenant un mois donc il n'est pas
question pour nous de couper ce fil il
faut expliquer la population et aux
demandes d'explication demande de
transparence et on se rend compte qu'une
fois qu'on explique les choses passent
beaucoup mieux les enjeux des situations
explosives sont là catherine conconne la
situation économique il faut tout revoir
des jeux au niveau gouvernemental sur
les aides amené à nos régions sur la
politique globale et générale du
développement économique dans nos pays
quelle quelle serait votre contribution
à cela il faut revoir le mode de
développement tout qu il faut quand même
comprendre et en ce moment je lis et
relis les interventions des six heures à
l'assemblée nationale dans les années 60
ces interventions sont toujours
d'actualité nous avons un cadre site
lionel qui est ce qu'il est je ne
demande pas de réformes
institutionnelles dans l'immédiat mais
il faut savoir que cette façon de
gouverner ses anciennes colonies que
nous sommes sous des régimes avec un
certain fétichisme du numéro d'article
le monde va très vite nous sommes pris
dans le rythme de la mondialisation
nous avons un pays à protéger je crois
protectionnisme pour moi il est
important que les productions
martiniquaise ne se voit pas assailli en
permanence paroisse du tout venant venue
de venus d'europe venus de france et que
les producteurs à la martinique ne
puisse pas vivre de le haut de leur
travail
il ya un certain nombre de choses à
revoir parce que je milite pour dire et
répéter que nous sommes un pays
singulier particulier il ya des
situations mais vraiment très exposés
d'air vous en était fait l'écho sur vos
les pages de vos réseaux sociaux vous
rappelez ces photos du centre
hospitalier du lamentin dans un état de
délabrement au moment où vous faisiez le
point d'ailleurs avec ces missionnaires
de l'igas sur l'administration ou
histoire du chu est ce qu'il y a eu une
avancée après la publication de ces
photos de votre indignation
j'attendais au retour puisque j'ai
adressé des courriers en bonne et due
forme aux igas suivi de mon communiqué
de presse il semblerait enfin c'est dans
l'air que certain nombre de principes
vont être arrêtés dans les jours qui
viennent
mais je suis désolé même si on doit
travailler un rétablissement financier
en rétablissement de la gouvernance
globale du chu de montigny on ne peut
pas nier qu'à quelques mètres d'eux des
bureaux de saisie gas et de la deûle à
l'ancienne direction qui vient de
quitter le pays
on est dans cet état de délabrement ce
alors cela ne peut pas dire et alors est
ce que les salariés du centre
hospitalier du lamentin est ce que la
population qui qui emmène ses proches se
faire soigner dans un tel établissement
est ce que tout ce tous et toutes ces
personnes peuvent se contenter
d'attendre une sénatrice dire j'ai écrit
et j'attends un rapport mais vous me
connaissez très bien monsieur le ton va
pas on va pas s'arrêter là
déjà voix et le courage et le dénoncer
alors que personne ne l'avait fait
jusqu'à présent c'est un solitaire pour
monsieur oui mais enfin être y être allé
parce que moi je ne m'attendais pas à
trouver une telle situation je ne vais
pas vous mentir ce propos quand j'étais
invité hors sol blanc je n'ai pas en
toute humilité
je ne suis pas une élue qui va répéter
sur tous les toits que je sais tout et
partout alors s'il ya des élus qui
savent tout et partout où j'ai envie de
dire tant mieux pour eux moi j'ai
l'humilité d'apprendre tous les jours
j'ai l'humilité dallas les formations
deux jours et il y à des sujets pour moi
quand l'hôpital du lamentin avait
déménagé à mon goût veut simple pour moi
même s'ils restaient une solution en
attend mais trouver ça trouver deux
enclaves au milieu de champs douine de
chant de désespérance humaine
toxicomanes prostituées et puis au
milieu vous avez un établissement qui a
moins de 20 ans je parle de l'immeuble
désherber à l'hémodialyse dans
lesquelles il n'ya plus d'ascenseur où
il ya de l'eau qui coule de dunes à tous
les étages les photos et/ou des
personnes d'un certain âge vont se faire
dialyser en montant des escales issus
des béquilles en se faisant pas honte et
parfois ceux des civière par des
ambulanciers
non ça peut pas durer concernant la
prison plus que vous avez entre les mais
désormais ce rapport rédigé par des
syndicats sur des propositions pour
améliorer la situation centre
pénitentiaire de ducos c'est tout récent
une suite déjà bien sûr il faut savoir
que j'avais déjà anticipé en me rendant
donc au ministère il y a quelques
semaines en disant ministère
parce que moi j'y tiens je crois que le
martiniquais doit écrire doit tenir la
plume de son destin j'étais à l'idée au
ministère dans le plan prisons avait nié
que vous êtes en train de préparer les
c'est la page la martinique blanche et
fin février début mars nous allons de
vous porter une contribution
donc j'ai travaillé avec y compris avec
les avocats un qui nous ont fait
remonter leurs propositions puisque
l'avocat est au contact de la prison
mais après un échange qui est un peu
difficile avec les syndicats parce que
moi j'avais crié urbi et orbi que je ne
souhaitais pas une deuxième raison c'est
à dire le copier coller de ducos et que
pour moi ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
aurait pu résoudre les difficultés de la
prison il en a eu un travail extrêmement
important je rends hommage à ces
syndicats qui ont joué le jeu qui se
sont ainsi qu'ils ont travaillé parce
que une fois de plus les meilleurs
spécialistes des affirme anti nicaise
sont les martiniquais
on verra ça avec autant de dossiers
c'est pour cela qu'on ne voudrait plus
en plénière de l'assemblée de martinique
catherine conconne à lorient c'était
exceptionnel parce que j'accompagnais
une amie très proche dans un deuil qui
la touchaient on a une vie aussi en
dehors de la vie d'élu mais vous savez
monsieur virton
leyrit suffoquant à la 7e l'air est
irrespirable à la cité m on y organise
tous les mois tous les mois et demi une
espèce de allez je vais oser le mot un
pit une séance de pete où il y a un
président de conseil exécutif que 6 ou
les auteurs des gradins et puis qui
lâcher comme ça pour y jouer une forme
de parodie de démocratie
dès que des commissions qu'ils se
réunissent pas qu'ils n'ont qu'une
valeur même la valeur de la vie ne
compte pas où il y un conseil exécutif
qui se croyaient tous les pouvoirs je
termine qui s'est octroyé tous les
pouvoirs et qui est qui voilà vous savez
c est encore une fois j'ai trouvé une
très belle formule pour juger ce genre
de choses il parlait de lattes et ato
cratie théâtre à raison les grecs qui
parle de gouvernance
votre groupe quand même puisque je
suppose que vous êtes au cou en contact
avec vos collègues dans son prix de
martinique nouvelle à la soul et de
martinique
votre groupe semble avoir du mal à
comprendre que les temps sont difficiles
qu'il y a des dettes à régler qu'il ya
des factures qu'on découvre miguel
laventure à d'ailleurs évoqué une
facture de 42 millions d'euros
découverte en début d'année à
l'opérateur public et à jouer oui
bonjour ça j'ai envie de dire mais en me
dis que cela rires ça fait deux ans
qu'on attend ça ça fait deux ans qu'on
nous assène ces stupidités qu'on lave le
cerveau dit martinique en permanence
pourrait signer pour essayer dans la
population que les fautifs c'est new
york j'ai entendu que c'était l'état qui
devait des dizaines de millions d'euros
sur l'aide sociale etc
il faut arrêter et être un peu
responsables moi si je prends l'exemple
nouvelles règles concernant c'est vrai
vous savez que monsieur malige n va est
le premier à signer avec l'état un pacte
de réduction de ses dépenses publiques
le premier de toutes les régions qui a
accepté d'aller avec l'état français
qu'il décrit tend vers une réduction qui
va forcément forcément impacter ses
compatriotes moi je crois au génie
martinique et je crois l'audace je crois
la détermination et bien si on doit
s'endetter on s'endette parce que les
pays bas qu'elles ne sont pas folle
lorsqu'elles prêtent à une collectivité
c'est qu'elles ont examiné ces ratios
varie de quelques chantres de la phase i
télé jeunes des sauts à la corde
ils sont tous à la commune de ninove
boeing ils sont est capable de conduire
l'avion ils sont incapables de le faire
voler et pour cela il faut trouver des
boucs émissaires
vous verrez que très bientôt après avoir
accusé l'opposition l'état on va bientôt
dire qu'ils sont victimes de quel bois
oui et catherine conconne votre groupe
d'autres cela puisque vous aimez dire
que l'équipe est à la tête de la cité
n'arrête pas de gémir de gémir de gémir
mais vous également vous gémissait non
pas du tout seul non non nous essaierons
de faire entendre vous savez le
martiniquais parfois sat sa tâche trop
pas la forme la politique celui du
passionnel et parfois le ton monte mais
il faut écouter le fond faut entendre ce
qu'on dit alors quand on essaie de se
faire comprendre à les élus font des coq
ans quand on me dit oh yeah
l'opposition paca 10 1 et c'est très
difficile de trouver un juste milieu
pour pour vaincre les gens qui a quelque
chose qui se passe dans ce pays
pendant que le chômage a fait un bond de
5% pendant que l'as cannes est en grande
souffrance parce que le plant kahn n'a
pas connu de suite alors que pourtant le
rhum fait est un produit d'excellence
qui s'exporte à 75% qui vient de rafler
des dizaines de médailles au salon de
l'agriculture que le feader n'est pas
consommé que les collèges et les lycées
sont en grande difficulté
la preuve ya des débrayages ce matin que
le prêcheur est abandonné j'adresse mes
mes encouragements aux mets à la
population du prêcheur si courrier
adressé à la ctm a presque eu de réponse
est comblé la rentrée de plus les
arguments qui n'existe pas mais là la
sénatrice elle résiste
la sénatrice aujourd'hui et tentent de
trouver des écossais au cuit d'essayer
de voir comment allait vraiment et
ironie de l'histoire on on appelle à se
faire dd j'ai dû écrire à la ministre
madame schiappa pour demander des aides
pour l'union des femmes de martinique
parce qu'ils ne sont pas aidés à la
juste valeur au niveau de la cité m
eh bien nous sommes obligés de retourner
à l'état c'est un peu infantile is an
mais c'est dommage mais c'est comme ça
merci d'avoir été ce père si l'on
souhaite être une cocotte sénatrice au
pmn de la martinique merci bonne journée
des great attaque